on poursuit notre série d'entrevues avec
les chefs la semaine dernière vous avez
entendu françoise david
ce soir françois legault monsieur
legault qui se sent regaillardi depuis
le dernier des bols débat de jeudi et
dernier il dit sentir sur le terrain un
grand changement est d'avoir de bons
chiffres
également on verra ce qui est sure il le
reconnaît c'est que la caq part de loin
beaucoup plus loin que la dernière fois
donc la côte est énorme à remonter je
les rencontre et il y a atteint une
heure au vieux port près du fleuve qu'il
chérit tant françois legault
bonjourbonjour soit on va parler du
fleuve dans quelques instants votre dada
arrête pas de sortir votre livre en
campagne mais d'abord je vous fait
réagir sur cette histoire qu'on a
diffusé d'alain gravel d'autres
histoires d'allégations de prête-noms
dans la course à la chefferie de madame
marois aux premières réactions
mais je pense à maroilles à répondre
savoir exactement qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pour que son mari
chercher du financement auprès de firmes
de génie je pense qu'on a droit de
réponse renfort de marwa mais n'en sais
pas plus que vous sur la pratique
générale des prête noms quand vous étiez
au parti québécois les libéraux l'ont
fait aussi ses documents datés parce
qu'on vit pas dans une immense
hypocrisie au québec où ça s'est fait
allègrement qui ont ici que ça siffle
mais moi j'en ai pas vu le mois juillet
du monde des affaires les gens qui
venaient à mon cocktail pour mon compte
et ça des gens d'affaires qui sortent à
ceux de leurs proches pour me faire
plaisir
c'est le bouche à e-cell plus le papier
des jeunes t'as pas vu depuis six mois
un arbre ce débat là que tu m'as dit ma
campagne mais moi j'en ai pas vu des
prête-noms sur intégrité qui qui est le
mieux positionné entre les libéraux et
les péquistes pour la suite des choses
bah écoutez le j'aurais aimé avoir
l'information de commission charbonneau
avant l'élection non notre deuxième
élection sans avoir toute l'information
eu beaucoup d'allégations
on a parlé du municipal on a parlé des
syndicats malheureusement on était rendu
à la porte leur nom et à moi j'aurais
aimé ça d'ailleurs moi je pense que la
commission charbonneau aurait dû
continuer de siéger pendant la campagne
électorale pour connaître plus
d'informations possibles avant de voter
mais je trouve ça malheureux qu'on
apprend eu toute l'information sur le
provincial certainement choses qui sont
dites là déjà je dirai pas qui ce retour
avec un mal de tête dans trois mois
en dix ans j'aurais donc dû faire un
autre vote mais pour vous la tuer ce que
les libéraux sont pires tp qui tout
c'est du pareil au même où john eu des
allégations l'assurait les deux parties
est ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
la coalition jamais été au courant qu'il
y aura pas de mauvaises surprises avec
la coalition a mené québec pour moi
personnellement non
j'ai pas de calais dans mon placard
est-ce que les deux autres peut dire la
même chose chez nous a déjà dit qu'il
lui était au courant de certaines choses
concernant les libéraux et les péquistes
qui a l'art de sa soeur mais j'en sais
pas plus que vous voulez et vous avez
voulu dès le départ par des d'économique
je passe une des campagnes on en a le
moins parler comme ça se fait c'est que
on est encore terrorisé par l'intégrité
et la souveraineté ces questions il ya
eu dans le fond deux agendas voir madame
marois depuis huit mois voulait parler
de sacha ne parvient chaque mois des
trains depuis quelques mots puis
monsieur couillard bien sauté sur
l'opportunité comme un petit gueule d'un
magasin de jouets cas de paris le
référent d'avocat capa d'otaries mais
que dit mon chien pour le pays
le monsieur couillard là je l'écoutais
un certain point de presse où certains
discours le froid il y avait juste un
sujet le référendum fait peur au monde
avec le référendum la vieille recette
libéral mais quand je regarde le
programme économique de monsieur
couillard je serais pas capable de dire
une idée qui est différente de ce que
jean charest affaire qui a pas
fonctionné parce que l'écart de richesse
grandi pendant les neuf années libéral
avec le reste du canada
la dette augmenter de 50% pendant les a
ni libérables mais ce qu'il a dit là que
lui il veut tout garder les structures
les commissions scolaires les agences
monsieur legault on a beaucoup
l'impression justement vous attaquez
beaucoup structure mecatherm de cantine
de souffle nouveau il ya 18 mois vous
vouliez en éducation mieux payer les
professeurs vient ajouter une heure à
l'école via ajouté des gens pour les
élèves en difficulté cette partie et on
dirait que vous vous vous raboter mais
n'ont-ils pas de nouveau je pense qu'il
faut se rendre compte actuellement que
de québec leur faut dire la vérité aux
québécois on n'a pas de marge de
manoeuvre
on n'a pas de marge de manoeuvre on a
des familles de la classe moyenne sont
étouffées donc c'est grave pour les
familles mais sega gossip au l'économie
quand on regarde la croissance
économique ce qui ralentit la croissance
c'est vraiment
la consommation n'a plus les moyens aux
dit de faire ce que l'humain vous aviez
promis il ya 18 ans exactement plus il
faut aller à l'essentiel c'est-à-dire
relancer l'économie en donnant un peu
d'air aux familles et puis avec la
proche à saint laurent mais moi ce que
je propose c'est qu'on se concentre sur
les facultés de génie pitt sciences de
la vie qu on les rapproche des
entreprises qu'on crée une vallée de
l'innovation dans la vallée du
saint-laurent et ça prend de l'argent
public safiot actuellement le ça prend
du courage
on a deux millions de dollars par année
de crédits d'impôts aux entreprises
ça donne pas des bons résultats donc
nous on est il ya des gens qui n'ont pas
aimé ça quand j'ai dis donc il y en
aurait plus crédit de 20 mille dollars
par année pour le multimédia et on
comprend dans les crédits d'impôt pour
les classes électroniques ont centré sa
wii 2
on va créer une grande innovation dans
vallée du saint-laurent et c'est comme
ça qu'on reconnaît des qualités mais je
me veux j'en reviens vexé en terminant
sur l'éducation je me souvient didier il
manque des gens pour nos enfants
difficulté on reste pas assez à l'école
les professeurs sont pas assez payés
c'était des idées qui était séduisante
pour les gens tout ce que j'ai oublié
son nom plus moyen la seule dépense que
le chien théorisé à mon équipe là c'est
l'aide aux enfants qui ont des
difficultés d'apprentissage ou moins que
ce que vous avez pris moins que la
dernière fois le cas toucher aux
salaires d'ailleurs l'épreuve les
enseignants disaient ce qu'ils veulent
sur tous et des ressources pour les
enfants qui ont des difficultés fois
j'ai très tôt de l'âge de 3 ans pour
donner des services aux enfants qui ont
des difficultés la pinte sens donc c'est
cela un endroit le seul endroit où j'ai
annoncé de nouvelles dépenses
manifestement vous remonter
déchets vous avez payé un sondage qui
très vite et assez bon est ce que vous
êtes partis de trop loin par contre
cette fois ci parce que vous partiez pas
de 27 parties de 12 13 14
c'est certain alors que là il reste une
semaine
par contre chant vraiment une énorme
changement sur le terrain je parle à peu
près tous les jours avec plusieurs de
mes collègues du monde autour de vous où
étaient les candidats le centre sur le
terrain surtout depuis les bords mais je
dirais aussi depuis qu'on parle moins de
référendum je pense que quand la
campagne a commencé vécu en avance d'un
sondage déjà qu'il est très pâle d'avoir
un gouvernement péquiste majoritaire le
serbe changé de côté donc les gens sont
pour me rassurer sur le référendum puis
enfin s'intéresse qui va être le
meilleur gestionnaire
ça peut-être choquer certaines personnes
mais en toute humilité
moi je pense que le travail qui à faire
actuellement c'est l'économie la bonne
gestion la baisse des taxes à cause de
mon passé je pense je suis la meilleure
personne
ouais vous avez dit à part ça vous avez
dit cette semaine où vous quand vous le
voulez ainsi les gros mots partout vous
avez dit on veut pas un médecin veut pas
d'une travailleuse sociale
c'était pas ça pour chaque chèque non
plus et sa secrétaire rené lévesque
jamais créé d'emplois
lucien bouchard jamais cru d'emploi le
truc dont je me crée d'emplois bourassa
non plus à ce compte là il est les
assume je me souviens parce que dans
l'histoire d'un peuple
il ya des moments où on a besoin d'un
profil différent actuellement alors on a
eu
un soldat personnes qui ont promis de
baisser les taxes n'ont jamais fait
premier la réingénierie l'ont jamais
fait on a besoin de quelqu'un qui va
aller faire ce qui était fait dans
plupart des pays dans un monde moderne
zénith et heures avec le plus efficace
pour dire qu'avec un coup il ya moins de
services non on connaît à fond
regardez ce que j'essaie d'expliquer
c'est ça mon principal défi là c'est
d'expliquer aux populations sur 570
mille employés qui travaillent le
gouvernement qu'on paye avec nos taxes
il ya en or 359 qui donne des services
sont touche pas au contraire on veut
même l'augmenter mais les 220 milles qui
sont dans les bureaux
c'est beaucoup plus quand on compare à
d'autres pays où d'autres provinces et
celle au pire on doit profiter de
l'attrition donc mais pas des gens qui
vivaient boomers se l'avouer pas des
gens guider si ça existe elle aurait
comme une annonce pour ce que je dis
depuis le début de la campagne
mon principal adversaire c'est pas le
parti de vannes parti québécois c'est la
résignation c'est que les gens se disent
je me suis fait tellement parler
maintenant baisses de taxes que je n'y
crois plus et c'est toute la classe
politique qui parle moi ce que je dis
aux gens non j'ai fait mes devoirs avec
christian dubé comptables agréés vous
avez je vais y arriver je vous promets
que dès cette année on va déposer un
budget on veut équilibrer le budget pour
commencer les taxes mais ça non mais
c'est le message de nos troupes à leur
passé mais votre équipe est moins forte
la dernière fois non s'agirait pas su
j'aurais po sont peut-être moins connus
bien que la dernière fois mais j'ai des
gens que j'avais pour la dernière très
bien serge proulx singes tremblay andry
la montagne déjà conditons expérience en
après ingestion petite question rappeler
qu'on finit là dessus sur nt vous là on
va régler ça ce que vous pensez
si madame marois remporte est ce que oui
ou non y aura un référendum d'après vous
n'êtes pas capable de dire a dit si les
gens sont très bons
le même jean françois lisée ticket
pessimiste donc surpris parce que déjà
plus de soixante dix pour cent des
québécois qui avaient même si le pq
l'emportent ce budget c'est pas grave
y'a pas de référendum mais ce que madame
marois va penser beaucoup de son énergie
à faire la promotion de la souveraineté
a plutôt que de s'occuper d'économie sur
sa musique
la charte est ce que on joue beaucoup
sur la peur des étrangères est ce que ça
commence par des dérapages seul c'était
irresponsable
d'abord de la part de monsieur charest
cinq ans a reçu le rapport vous chantez
moi j'appuie essentiellement le rapport
du short hand interdit pour les
personnes qui sont en notre but est
d'importer des singles du sujet rien
faire madame avoir pendant 18 mois a
fait exprès pour le site rennais de
aussi comment cette dangereuse et très
dense est un dossier qui divise yves qui
est sensible qui est émotif c'était
irresponsable d'apport de madame marois
de pour régler le dossier
si un gouvernement minoritaire péquiste
ou libéral
est-ce que vous excluez d'aller
travailler avec nous vous allez pas
marqué dans des hypothèses comme cela
moi je m'en vais là pour gagner un
gouvernement majoritaire la cohésion et
curé puis jusqu'aux certes au soir vous
allez m'entendre parler juste de ça sur
la gauche
bonne fin de campagne